what if Natalie Portman battled the
undead in Pride and Prejudice and
Zombies and would John Krasinski have
won best actor for Manchester by the Sea
these are Hollywood's biggest what-ifs
Gone Girl is a 2014 psychological
Thriller that tells the story of Nick
Dunn and his missing wife Amy who
disappears on the day of their fifth
wedding anniversary the prime suspect in
the case Nick must try to clear his name
while uncovering the truth about what
has happened to Amy the film is based on
Gillian Flynn's 2012 novel and was a
financial and critical hit earning 369
million dollars worldwide against a
reported 61 million dollar budget
according to Box Office Mojo according
to the Washington Post Reese Witherspoon
played a major part in developing the
film and was initially set to Star as
Amy however the role eventually went to
Rosemont Pike who is not much younger
than Witherspoon speaking in a
Roundtable event hosted by The Hollywood
Reporter Witherspoon revealed that after
talking with director David Fincher she
came to the conclusion that she was not
the right person to portray Amy on
screen whatever conversation Witherspoon
and Fincher had seemed to have been for
the best Not only was Pike widely
praised for her performance in the movie
but she was also nominated for the
Academy Award for best actress you think
I'd let him destroy me and end up
happier than ever
[Music]
directed by Martin Scorsese the crime
Thriller that departed was actually a
remake of the 2002 film infernal Affairs
the story follows two undercover agents
one working for the mob and one for the
police as they try to infiltrate each
organization and uncover the identity of
the opposing mole the film stars
Leonardo DiCaprio as state trooper
William Costigan Matt Damon as the mob
spy Colin Sullivan and Jack Nicholson as
mob boss Frank Costello Brad Pitt and
his production company Plan B purchased
the rights to remake Internal Affairs
beating out disgraced film producer
Harvey Weinstein via variety the actor
and producer told interview magazine
that he worked on the project for more
than two years to try and get it made
before securing the services of Scorsese
and scriptwriter William Monahan early
reports suggested that Pitt would take
on the part of Sullivan in the movie
however the actor stepped back from the
role when Scorsese signed on to direct
in the same interview Pitt explained I
thought it would be better if they were
younger guys that were just starting
their lives guys coming out of the
academy guys who are hungry I thought I
was too old for it although the Batman
was originally meant to be part of the
DC extended Universe the Matt Reeves
directed movie is now considered a
standalone project separate from the
larger continuity this is largely down
to the insistence of the director who
wanted to tell an earlier story about
the Caped Crusader and his struggles to
battle crime and Gotham this version of
the movie was co-written with Peter
Craig and stars Robert Pattinson I'm
Vengeance the Batman had a troubled
production like mini DC movie projects
and it wasn't clear when it would
actually get made Ben Affleck who had
already portrayed Batman in three
earlier films was set to direct write
and star in the movie but by 2017
variety was reporting that Affleck had
chosen to step down from directing
duties to focus on producing and
Performing the actor later chose to exit
the project altogether explaining his
decision in 2019 Affleck said he
couldn't get the film to work and felt
the that it would be better if someone
else filled the role and provided a
fresh take on the character he also
revealed the New York Times in 2020 that
he had stepped back from the Batman due
to a combination of personal issues this
includes his alcoholism and divorce from
Jennifer Gardner as well as his negative
experience working on Justice League
based on Marie Brenner's 1997 Vanity
Fair article American Nightmare The
Ballad of Richard Jewell this movie
focuses on the real life story of
security guard Richard Jewell he
discovered the explosives at the
Centennial Olympic Park bombing and
subsequently became a suspect in the
investigation directed by Clint Eastwood
it features Paul Walter Hauser as Jewel
and Sam Rockwell as attorney general
Watson Bryant Jr with Kathy Bates Jon
Hamm and Olivia Wilde all having major
roles while it was not a financial
success failing to make back its 45
million dollar budget according to Box
Office Mojo the film received largely
positive reviews please clear mess us
name
Jonah Hill and Leonardo DiCaprio were
both attached to the film early on and
were expected to both produce and star
deadline reported in 2014 that Hill
would play jewel while DiCaprio would
take on the part of Jules lawyer updates
were few after that until Clint Eastwood
was eventually signed to direct it was
confirmed in 2019 that the two actors
would no longer appear in the film with
Eastwood instead looking to put together
his own cast via deadline however Hill
and DiCaprio stayed on his producers
for many people murder mystery is likely
just another film in a long line of Adam
Sandler comedies but it has proved
successful enough for Netflix to
Greenlight a sequel that has already
begun filming the first movie sees
police officer Nick Spitz and his wife
Audrey played by Sandler and Jennifer
Aniston as they turn into murder
investigators after witnessing a
billionaire killed on his own yacht
during a party
survive him he's got a knife plunged in
his heart I don't think he's Revival
both director John Madden and actor
Charlize Theron were attached to murder
mystery when it was first developed the
pair were first linked to the project by
The Hollywood Reporter back in 2012 thr
later revealed that Madden and Theron
had dropped out of the project although
there was no reason given why Theron was
eventually credited as an executive
producer with her production company
Denver and Delilah Productions also
involved in a minor way by the time
filming started in 2018 Kyle knew a
check was at the helm with Sandler and
Aniston as the leads Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies is a comedy horror film that
follows the basic story of Jane Austen's
novel Pride and Prejudice but mashes it
together with modern zombie elements the
end result is a movie where the Bennett
sisters search for suitable suitors
while also defending themselves from
hordes of the undead burst ears led the
project writing and directing the film
while Lily James and Sam Riley starred
however James was not the first person
considered for the lead role of
Elizabeth Bennett in 2009 variety
reported that Natalie Portman would be
producing and starring in the film
through her own production company
handsome Charlie films her departure
from Pride and Prejudice and Zombies
came two days after David O Russell also
left the project as per the Wall Street
Journal Russell seemingly quit following
a dispute with Lion Gates about the
film's proposed budget although no
reason was given for why Portman would
no longer appear New York Magazine
suggested it may have been down to
scheduling conflicts she continued to
serve as a producer
yes man is a 2009 romantic comedy
starring Jim Carrey as Carl a man who
attempts to turn his life around by only
saying yes to any and all opportunities
the plot is partly based on the Yes Man
book written by Danny Wallace who lived
his life saying yes for six months
before Wallace's Memoir was even
published Warner Brothers purchased the
rights to make a film according to the
advocate Jack Black and his school of
rock collaborator Mike White were set to
develop the movie with producer David
Heyman who stayed with the project
there's been no definite reason given
for why black and white left yes man but
vulture suggested that it was likely
down to the actor being involved in
other films and unable to make room in
his schedule this does make sense
considering that the actor was involved
in the high profile movies Be Kind
Rewind Kung Fu Panda and Tropic Thunder
all around the same time
in the 2019 drama Lucy in the Sky space
Explorer Lucy Cola played by Natalie
Portman returns to earth following a
space mission but finds her life
deteriorating as she struggles to find
meaning this eventually culminates in an
attack on two fellow astronauts as she
suffers from hallucinations and paranoia
directed and written by Noah Hawley who
had previously worked on television
series such as Fargo and Legion it was a
huge financial failure grossing just
over three hundred thousand dollars
according to Box Office Mojo variety
confirmed in 2017 that Fox Searchlight
had partnered with Reese Witherspoon
Bruno papandrea and Noah Hawley to
produce the film which at that point was
titled pale blue dot Witherspoon was
expected to Star as Lucy and was
attached as a producer through her
company Pacific Standard later that year
Witherspoon announced that she was
stepping down from the cast but would
remain as a producer with deadlines
speculating that this was probably so
that she could film a second season of
big little lies
following the success of its other
original movies Apple has recently been
working on a film titled project Artemis
based on NASA's Artemis program to get
humans back on the moon for the first
time in more than 50 years when the film
was first announced Scarlett Johansson
Chris Evans and Jason Bateman were all
involved Evans and Johansen were
expected to star in the movie working
together for the first time since they
appeared in Avengers endgame in 2019
despite the fact that the two had
expressed a desire to team up again it
was revealed just a few months later
that Evans had been forced to quit the
role due to scheduling conflicts the
Apple release would have caused issues
for filming on two of his other upcoming
movies pain Hustlers and Big Red One
an emotional and deeply personal story
Manchester by the Sea focuses on the
life of a man who is stricken with guilt
and grief following the death of his
three children this is something that he
was unintentionally responsible for by
accidentally starting the house fire
that killed them shocked to find that he
has been named his nephew's legal
guardian following the death of his
brother he is forced to confront his
past and deal with his turmoil the film
was lauded by critics with a 96 approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes in particular
praise for star Casey Affleck who won an
Academy Award for best actor Matt Damon
was heavily involved in Manchester by
the sea from its conception according to
Rolling Stone Damon developed the basic
idea for the story with actor John
Krasinski the pair later approached
writer director Kenneth Lonergan to
further expand the plot and come up with
a screenplay explaining the creative
process in an interview with variety
Lonergan said that Damon was set to
direct the film while Krasinski would
have starred as the leading character
the two actors ended up being
unavailable and had to drop out as they
were busy with other projects leaving
the space open for Casey Affleck to take
over in the main role and Lonergan to
direct we don't know exactly what we're
doing 25th hour a film written by Game
of Thrones showrunner David benioff and
based on his novel of the same name
tells the story of Monty Brogan as he
enjoys one final day of Freedom about to
go to prison over a drug deal conviction
and having been sentenced to seven years
behind bars he explores New York and
spends time with some of his family and
friends he recalls the events that led
him to this moment and his potential
future Spike Lee took on directing
duties while Edward Norton starred as
Monty speaking to the guardian in 2003
benioff revealed how Tobe Maguire had
expressed an interest in producing and
starring in a film adaptation of the
novel The actor had read a preliminary
copy some six months before it was due
to be published and acquired the rights
McGuire requested that binioff write the
screenplay but was ultimately forced to
back out of starring in the film due to
his commitments with Spider-Man however
like many actors on this list he
remained as a producer
[Music]